>> PRESIDENT TRUMP VOWED WE
WOULD FINALLY WIN THE WAR
AGAINST ISIS UNDER HIS WATCH.
>> WE WILL FIGHT YOU.
WE WILL DESTROY YOU AND WE WILL
WIN!
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> I WOULD BOMB THE [BLEEP] OUT
OF THEM.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> THIS IS AN EVIL, SADISTIC,
MONSTEROUS ENEMY.
WE MUST KEEP THESE KILLERS OUT
OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> WE WILL KNOCK OUT ISIS SO
VIOLENTLY AND SO FAST.
ISIS IS GOING TO GET ONE BRUTAL
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> AS HIS FIRST YEAR IN OFFICE
CLOSES OUT, THERE IS EXTREMELY
POSITIVE EVIDENCE WE MAY BE
GETTING CLOSER THAN EVER.
ISIS LOST 98% OF ITS TERRITORY
IN IRAQ AND SYRIA.
THERE ARE STILL MAJOR HURDLES
BUT THIS IS ENCOURAGING NEWS.
MY QUESTION FOR YOU, YOU KNEW
YOU WOULD GET THIS FIRST.
>> I COULD SENSE IT.
>> SO, LOOK, TO ASK THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE, THEY WOULD SAY THAT
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT
TOUGH ENOUGH.
DIDN'T TAKE ENOUGH STEPS.
WE HEARD COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE
RULES OF ENGAGEMENT.
>> SOME OF THAT IS JUST
POLITICS.
THE STRATEGY THAT LED TO A
VIRTUAL DEFEAT OF ISIS IN SYRIA
AND IRAQ IS LARGELY A STRATEGY
THAT WAS LAID OUT DURING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION BY MILITARY
COMMANDERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALLOWED THE
MILITARY TO USE MORE BOMBS.
WHAT IS THE STRATEGY GOING
ISIS FIGHTERS WHO WILL GO BACK
TO EUROPE AND GO ON LINE AND
RADICALALIZE PEOPLE LIKE WE HAVE
SEEN HERE IN THE U.S.
THIS IS A GOOD STEP, BUT THE
FIGHT WILL CONTINUE IN A
DIFFERENT AND ALMOST MORE
DANGEROUS WAY.
>> KATIE, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE THREAT HERE DOMESTICALLY.
NEXT.
ONE OF THE REASONS, BY THE WAY,
IS DUE, PART OF THE GO SLOW IS
WHO WILL GOVERN SYRIA?
>> RIGHT.
I WOULD NOT ARGUE THAT THE ISIS
STRATEGY IS COMPLETELY ABOUT
SYRIA.
IT'S ABOUT GETTING BACK THE
TERRITORY IN IRAQ.
THEY WERE DOWN PLAYED DURING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
IT WAS NOT REPORTED THAT 80% OF
THE CASUALTIES IN AFGHANISTAN
AND IRAQ HAPPENED UNDER OBAMA'S
WATCH AS A RESULT OF THIS RULES
YOU CAN GIVE PRESIDENT OBAMA
CREDIT FOR THE STRATEGY, BUT
GIVE CREDIT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR LISTENING TO THEM AND
GETTING THE JOB DONE.
THE THING GOING FORWARD WITH THE
GLOBAL WAR ON TERROR, THERE IS A
VICTORY NOW.
NATURE OF THE THREATS WE FACE.
IT'S A HUGE VICTORY.
NOT ONLY JUST FOR GETTING RID OF
ISIS BUT ALSO FOR THE MILITARY
TO FEEL LIKE THEY CAN DO THEIR
JOB AGAIN.
>> KENNEDY, WILL WE HAVE TROOPS
IN IRAQ AND SYRIA FOREVER?
>> IT FEELS LIKE AND AFGHANISTAN
UNFORTUNATELY.
WHENEVER WE HAVE GOOD NEWS, YOU
WONDER:
WHAT IS THE NEXT STEP?
WHAT IS THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF THE
UNITED STATES?
THERE ARE U.S. ENTER  --
INTERESTS THAT HAVE TO BE
SECURED IN THOSE PLACES.
THE REALITIES OF GOVERNING ARE
DIFFERENT.
KATIE IS RIGHT.
WE CAN'T HANG MISSION
ACCOMPLISHED BANNERS, BECAUSE
THIS CAN GO SO MANY DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS.
SYRIA DEVOLVED INTO CIVIL WAR.
THE PRESIDENT HAS PEOPLE AROUND
HIM WHO UNDERSTAND THE COST OF
HUMAN LIFE AND THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING.
WHY ARE WE SPENDING 7 TRILLION
DOLLARS IN OVERSEAS WARS WHEN WE
SHOULD BE SPENDING THAT IN THIS
COUNTRY MAKING OUR BRIDGES AND
ROADS BETTER?
>> NATION BUILDING HERE AT HOME
IS THE PHRASE.
TOM?
>> I LIKE THE GENERAL!
>> YOU ARE PRO-GENERALS.
>> [LAUGHING]
>> I STAND WITH THE MEN AND
WOMEN IN UNIFORM.
ONE OF THE BIG ADVANTAGES OF
THIS IS THAT IT DENIES ISIS AND
THE PEOPLE WHO CALL THEMSELVES
ISIS A REACTORING TOOL.
-- RECRUITING TOOL.
THEY COULD SAY WE ARE BUILDING
OUR OWN NATION IN THE DESERT.
THE PHYSICAL DEFEAT OF IT DENIES
THEM A RECRUITING POINT.
THIS IS THE  PATH ONLINE.
>> THAT'S WHY WINNING IS
IMPORTANT.
TRUMP IS ALL ABOUT WINNING AND
IT'S TRUE WITH ISIS.
THE MORE WINS YOU RACK UP THE
BETTER.
IT'S DOWN NOW.
WE WANT TO KEEP SNUFFING IT OUT
AND COUNT UP THE VICTORIES.
EVERYBODY HATES ISIS.
WE ARE TOGETHER ON THAT.
I GIVE PRESIDENT OBAMA CREDIT
WHEN HE HAD SUCCESS IN THAT
AREA.
I THINK IT WAS GREAT WHEN HE
WENT BACK ON HIS WORD AND KEPT
GUANTANAMO BAY.
I WAS GLAD HE BROKE THAT
PROMISE.
WHEN HE GOT IN THERE, THE
FOREIGN POLICY AGAINST ISIS WAS
NOT THAT DRAMATICALLY CHANGED
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
I THINK PRESIDENTS DO TAKE THE
ADVICE OF THE GENERALS.
>> WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA, THERE
WERE FROM BOB GATES TO PEOPLE IN
THE PENTAGON, WHEN THEY LEFT THE
ADMINISTRATION THEY TALKED ABOUT
HOW DIFFICULT IT WAS.
THEY WOULD LAYOUT PLANS FOR
DEFEATING ISIS AND PRESIDENT
OBAMA HAD HIS OWN PLANS ON HOW
TO DO IT.
>> BOB GATE WAS NOT REALLY
THERE.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> THE PROBLEM PRESIDENT OBAMA
CAME UP AGAINST IS EVERY BOMB
LOOKS LIKE A HAMMER.
THERE HAVE TO BE OTHER TOOLS.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> THERE HAVE TO BE OTHER TOOLS
TO GO AFTER THREATS.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> NO, NO, NO, LISTEN.
HE RAN ON ENDING THE WAR IN
IRAQ.
>> WHICH CREATED ISIS BY THE
WAR IN AMERICA'S HISTORY IN
AFGHANISTAN.
HOME.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD 8 YEARS
TO END THAT WAR.
>> AND HE DIDN'T.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT AMERICAN
DIPLOMACY AND ECONOMIC POWER.
>> THAT DIDN'T WORK WELL WITH
ISIS.
THE BOMBING OF ISIS.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> WHAT BECOMES OF SYRIA?
>> RIGHT.
>> IT'S GREAT TO HAVE ISIS,
GREAT TO HAVE THE PEOPLE,
EVERYONE HATES.
>> [LAUGHING]
>> ISIS JOINING THE RANKS OF THE
IRAQI GOVERNMENT IN PLACES WHERE
IT IS NOT STABLE.
THERE IS ALWAYS ANOTHER PROBLEM
THAT WE WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
BOMBING MORE.
IN TERMS OF HOW WE MOVE FORWARD.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THESE GUYS
POLICY.
>> I AGREE WITH MARIE.
WE HAVE TO BE MORE MINDFUL THAN
EVER OF THE DIGITAL COUNTER
STIT.
-- COUNTERFEIT.
THE PEOPLE WHO SCATTERED.
THEY ARE DOWN TO 1,000.
YOU HAVE 44,000 -- THEY HAVE
GONE TO PLACES IN WESTERN
EUROPE.
THEY ARE RADICALIZING IN WAYS WE
HAVE SEEN HERE IN NEW YORK CITY
WITH TWO TERROR ATTACKS THIS
YEAR.
>> IT USED TO BE YOU COULD TRACK
SOMEBODY'S TRAVEL AND IT WAS A
RED NAG.
>> WILL WE ORCHESTRATE REGIME
CHANGES?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CHANGED HIS
VIEW ON SYRIA.
CAME IN, WHAT DO I CARE?
HOW LONG DID IT TAKE TO START
BOMBING SYRIA.
PRESIDENTS CHANGE WHEN THEY GET
IN HERE.
>> DO WE END UP CONFRONTING
RUSSIA?
>> WELL, MAYBE IF WE CAN GET
THIS INVESTIGATION COME TO A
CLOSE.
>> [LAUGHING]
>> MAYBE TRUMP OFFICE MUELLER A
DEAL.
>> IF YOU LISTEN TO THE LEFT, WE
ARE NOT FIGHTING AGAINST RUSSIA.
WE ARE FIGHTING WITH RUSSIA.
WE ARE A PUPPET OF THE SOVIET
REGIME AND DO WHAT PUTIN WANTS.
ADMINISTRATION.
>> DO YOU THINK HE STASE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I WON'T PREDICT THAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS VERY
FOCUSSED ON IRAN AND MAKING SURE
INBOUND.
>> EVERYONE'S DAYS ARE NUMBERED.
>> LAST WORD?
>> THE PROBLEM IS IN ASSAD IS